well the guidance across the four
nations of the uk is now looking
quite different and we can explain more
in england
38 million people at 68 percent of the
population will be living under tighter
coronavirus restrictions
from tomorrow between the 23rd and 27th
of december up to
three households can form a bubble but
boris johnson has also
not ruled out another national lockdown
after
christmas well in scotland tighter rules
have been imposed in three council areas
from this evening
these are aberdeen aberdeenshire and
east lothian with restrictions on
movement
leisure activities and hospitality
people are being advised to stay
in their own home with their own
household at christmas and to meet on
one day only
and in wales just two households can get
together over the festive period
and wales will go back into a national
lockdown from december the 28th for at
least
three weeks christmas regulations in
northern ireland are the same as
in england meaning a total of up to
three households may still
mix but it will enter a six-week
lockdown
beginning on boxing day
you